Schwarzenegger you guys actually hated
each other for a while well we were very
competitive yeah I think Hate's a good
word it is it was all about who is uh
making bigger movies who has uh uh more
definition in the muscles who has bigger
knives I heard that he tricked you into
doing the movies that didn't work for
you there was a there's a there's a
thing you know when people play pray on
your insecurities I was wanting to get
out of just doing action movies and do
comedies so they came to me with this
other movie next to you is my son mom
stay out of this okay I read the script
and it was a bus I mean let's be honest
then Sly called me and I said yes I was
thinking about doing it your agent goes
you got to do this movie you got to do
this movie because Arnold's going to do
it I go really I go okay I'll do it so
he did the movie of course the movie
went Maj into the
toilet